this time last year we were heading into
the worst wave of the pandemic so far
with hospital admissions in england on
the steep rise towards 4 000 a day
fast forward to last month and here we
can see a similarly sharp increase
the good news is that daily admissions
remain below half what they were
at the peak
but ministers are concerned about a rise
in hospital admissions among older
population groups the over 85 is a
relatively small pool of people but
adjusted for population has been the
worst affected throughout the pandemic
more broadly admission rates are going
up in all adult age groups shown by this
uptick
in december
this is a snapshot of confirmed coveted
patients in hospital in the past three
months increasing evidence is that
omicron is a milder variant of covid but
it spreads incredibly quickly
to see what this means in hospital we
can divide the total number of patients
into three groups the first the dark
line at the top is the people in
hospital for another ailment but test
positive for the virus through routine
testing they now make up about a third
of confirmed covet patients
the more important block the one in the
middle the light blue block is the
number of people in hospital for covert
treatment the most critically ill those
on mechanical ventilators the bottom
line are here
this number has remained pretty stable
so increasing numbers of patients in
hospital for covid but they're not as
ill as in previous waves
general trends are a helpful tool but
it's more of a mixed bag when we break
the data down by regions the rest of
england is estimated to be about 10 days
behind london you can see hospital
admissions starting
rising in the capital from mid december
but and it's a very cautious but there
are the first signs of a slowdown
according to the head of nhs providers
government ministers will be keeping an
eye on this other regions of england are
still on the rise adjusted for
population hospital admissions in the
northwest and the midlands
are shooting up
remember this data won't reflect
household mixing at christmas due to the
lag between catching coved and serious
illness and it will be another week or
two before we see a potential impact of
schools going back
a lot
still hangs
in the balance